décidément l'actualité de cette fin de
semaine aura été dominée par la sphère
patrick dils avec aujourd'hui à nouveau
rebondissement une autre première dans
les annales judiciaires puisque l'avocat
du condamné a décidé de faire appel dès
demain à troisième procès aura donc lieu
une troisième comparution devant
d'autres jurés un cas de figure
totalement inédit et exceptionnel afin
d'obtenir devant une nouvelle cour
d'assises l'acquittement peut-être de
celui qui continue de clamer son
innocence
joël bruandet jérôme soûlard et sylvain
gauthier
je ne me suis pas battu 14 ans pour en
arriver là vous faites comme vous voulez
mais moi je continue c'était vendredi
soir patrick dils vient d'être condamné
à 25 ans de réclusion criminelle alors
que l'avocat général avait requis
l'acquittement il annonce aussitôt à ses
avocats son intention de continuer le
combat en choisissant de faire appel
patrick dils abandonne la possibilité
d'une libération conditionnelle
il devra donc attendre son troisième
procès en prison là où il a déjà passé
14 ans pour ses parents persuadés de
l'innocence de leur fils ce choix est
celui de l'honneur
taille restreinte et non en prison
depuis longtemps mais en est un que nous
le troisième procès sortir enfin libre
et blanchi c'est ça que nous on attend
et patrick ou 6 mai pour les familles
des victimes le prix de l'honneur sera
lourd à payer un nouveau procès avec
encore une douleur à vif
malheureusement on s'aperçoit qu'encore
une fois on est obligé de continuer
encore à se défendre finalement à
éprouver les sensations et les émotions
que nous réserve des nouveaux procès
donc c'est encore une épreuve
supplémentaire mais je dis je reconnais
dans un mondial dans une perspective
désormais tout à fait différente car
après les deux chances qu'ils ont été
détenus à patrick dils cette troisième
mon avis est un peu superfétatoire grave
depuis janvier dernier un condamné peut
faire appel d'un verdict de cour
d'assises une possibilité que patrick
dils a choisi de ne pas refuser et ce
malgré la souffrance inévitable imposé
aux parties civiles vont que cette
poursuite de la procédure
correspond pour eux à une poursuite de
leur calvaire
malheureusement si ils sont victimes
nous avons quant à nous la certitude que
patrick dils est une troisième victime
est donc n'auront pas le choix quinze
ans après le meurtre de cyril et
alexandre patrick dils devrait donc être
rejugé d'ici un an ce sera alors la
première fois dans toute l'histoire
judiciaire française qu'un homme sera
rejugé trois fois pour le même crime